là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'ils apprennent à tricoter
d'accord là-dessus à votre place je la
ramène un peu moins mais si vous ne
réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous manque
qu'une seule chose que de petits détails
le
pari de ce qui lui arrive à la baisse
bonjour à tous et bonne année bien sûr
toute l'équipe de l'inattendu se joint à
moi pour vous souhaiter le meilleur en
2022 notre promesse reste inchangé à
vous offrir un voyage dans le temps à
travers les archives de la télévision
pour mieux comprendre l'actualité
contemporaine c'est l'inattendu et vous
êtes les bienvenus sur notre nouveau
plateau ludivine camille le père noël
nous a gâtés regardez comme c'est beau
alors qu'amy on va commencer avec la
revue de presse et l'homme de la semaine
et qui est il et bien c'est michel
houellebecq l'écrivain sort son dernier
roman cette semaine son 8e le titre
c'est anéantir et regardez il est
qualifié de prophètes de la déprime
moderne mais c'est un peu étonnant oui
mais c'est pourtant d'un titre qu'on
aurait déjà pu lui donner à la sortie de
son premier roman qui s'appelait
extension du domaine de la lutte en 1994
il le présente sur le plateau du cercle
de minuit face à laure adler et déjà
surprise l'auteur des primes aux coups
de chansons sont dépressifs je veux dire
c'est une
c'est une dépression
moi je dirais banal et même inévitable
enfin est donc bon forcément quand on
vieillit quand on partait un certain âge
on est plus adapté donc en fait on
devient une espèce de déchets sociale en
tout cas vous n'avez pas déprimer assez
puisque vous avez eue la possibilité
d'écrire cette ce lent processus vers la
dépression robin cantin almost et
surtout la poésie au départ quand on en
sort on est sauvé le monde devient
différent voilà vous l'avez entendu un
déchet social avec la vieillesse donc
michel houellebecq déjà prophète de la
déprime en 1994 et on a observé sur les
archives il avait une cigarette sur le
plateau incroyable autre fait marquant
cette semaine ludivine le décès d'igor
bogdanoff
oui il avait 72 ans igor bogdanoff est
mort quelques jours après son frères
grichka les jumeaux avaient contracté le
qu'ovide 19 igor et grichka bogdanoff
frère jumeau jusque dans la mort titrait
cette semaine libération justement ce
lien gémellaire les deux hommes ont
souvent évoqué à la télévision c'était
le cas en 1988 dans l'émission télé
caroline sur fr3 l'animatrice caroline
tresca les interrogeait sur le sujet
j'avais lu justement quelques un article
dans une revue psychologique ou qui
disait vous êtes vous donner une
définition de vous-même vous disiez nous
sommes des homosexuels le rap est là je
sais pas à quoi c'est igor qui écrit oui
c'est moi qui est qui et qui avec l'esa
quelque part parce que c'était pas
c'était pas une interview c'était un je
crois que c'était un texte il écrit et
en fondant un texte on peut toujours
aller vers des informations plus subtil
plus sensible plus fine en tout cas que
la parole lorsque elle vole comme ça et
que quelquefois elle vous emporte au
delà du sens en réalité quand je dis aux
mots sensuel c'est très simple on sent
la même chose c'est le reste y homo
sensualité ça veut dire que bon deux
jumeaux ressentent exactement la même
chose au même moment ce sont les aides
qui sont tout à fait particulier parce
que ils ont bénéficié d'une expérience
de vie commune ils en bénéficient d'une
histoire commune connaissent les mêmes
gens aient finalement leurs réactions
sont fondées sur les mêmes principes et
à partir de là donc vous êtes vous sûr
du monde son humeur générale non mais je
suis fan
voilà l'homosexualité c'est comme ça
qu'ils gore bogdanov décrivait la
relation qu'il avait avec son frère
voilà les frères bogdanoff en 1988
c'était l'époque de temps x l'émission
qui a marqué pas mal de gnr on dont moi
voilà c'est comme ça voilà pour
l'actualité cette semaine mais que s'est
il passé à cette même période de l'année
par le passé c'est le zapping de
l'inattendu regarder
bonjour
télégramme laconique du secrétariat de
l'ancien président de la république
annonce à l'instant la mort de monsieur
françois mitterrand
pour de nombreux automobilistes c'est
déjà trop tard
depuis longtemps sur une montée de 300 m
cinq centimètres de glace vif ont patiné
les camions et c'est parti pour 24
heures de galère les gens ça fait
dix-sept deezer qui sont dehors bagnols
a fauté comme des cons ces gens que vous
aimez travailler consciencieusement son
employé dans une fabrique de l'ue
mettent pour chiens
comme ça
ça va lui permettre de cicatriser ce que
vous ne croyez pas que vous allez
recevoir beaucoup de doléances oui enfin
j'espère qu'on voudra bien admettre que
tous les poissons qui crèvent dans les
rivières ne crève pas par ma faute
michel galabru en imposait par sa voix
par ses mimiques par ses colères il
était aussi un boulimique du cinéma j'ai
joué tous les grands classiques et des
plus fins et ça ne me rapporte rien pas
un article dans un journal pas une
publicité et c'est quand j'ai commencé à
jouer des textes un peu chétif un peu
bête que tout est venu
entendez bien ce que je vous dis plus
c'était bête plus nous sommes engagés
[Musique]
la nouvelle année c'est pour beaucoup
l'occasion de prendre de bonnes
résolutions à arrêter de fumer arrêtez
de boire perdre du poids faire du sport
des décisions louable et le plus souvent
sincère ludivine sur une bonne
résolution peut-être une bonne
résolution je vais essayer d'être un peu
moins gourmandes même si là en cette
période de galettes des rois j'avoue que
c'est un peu mal barré c'est la
parenthèse et vous nathanaël derrière
moi c'est super simple c'est la même
chaque année être ponctuel être à
l'heure en tout cas moi ça va être
facile ça
bon en tout cas en tout cas c'est pas
mal mais sachez que le sujet bonne
résolution est un incontournable des jt
et ça depuis longtemps le grand
classique c'est le micro trottoir avec
bien sûr toujours cette même question
nous allons bientôt être en 1988 est ce
que vous avez pensé à prendre quelques
résolutions et savoir si vous avez pris
de bonnes résolutions pour 93 est-ce que
vous avez pris des résolutions pour 96
chaque année c'est la question qui
taraude les journalistes pourtant au fil
des ans les réponses ne change pas
vraiment certaines résolutions traverse
les âges la première arrêter de fumer ou
en tout cas diminue moins fumer wish
mais arrêter non
je vais arrêter de fumer première
résolution c'est de ne plus fumer je
pense que je trouve que c'est pas bon
pour la santé et quand on fait deux
heures de spectacle qu'il faut être
raisonnable donc je ne fume plus et
pudique
nouvelle année rime donc avec bonne
santé alors pour beaucoup régie des
sports sont inédits tarder un petit
régime parce que on prend ma peau des
kilos en 92 93 ans on fait attention ça
va c'est décidé je perds 10 kg et puis
je suis la gym et puis bon j'entretiens
ma forme d'îlots au moins quatre kilos
nager courir
voilà 2016 cette année on se prendre
dans le lot des bonnes résolutions il ya
aussi celles plus pragmatique depuis
longtemps le travail et l'argent font
partie des préoccupations des français
beaucoup d'argent juste revenu du
travail
il ya l'otan
je suis chômeur je compte trouver du
boulot espère que en étant commercial
que j'arriverai toujours à négocier
quelques dossiers toujours des sous et
du travail après les sous et le travail
place maintenant à une vision plus
philosophique des résolutions de début
d'année les voeux de bonheur sagesse
amour et altruisme traverse les
générations
il faut peut-être penser en termes de
solidarité m jean qui avec tout le monde
s'est trouvé l'amour de ma vie ça
sentait bonnes résolutions déjà moi j'ai
fait la résolution d'être remaniée avec
mes parents ne plus mentir car plaisir
ma femme comme j'ai toujours fait
jusqu'à présent mais révolution à moi de
faire l'amour vient faire la fête et
s'amuser mais en profiter chaque année
je me dis je vais être pouces h marche
pas à leur moulin on dit autre chose et
enfin reconnaissons le la résolution
numéro un dans les archives c'est tout
de même celle ci on compte pas vécu bien
voir du tout
résolution de mont joli surnom gibloux
tout ça ne sert à rien les bonnes
résolutions on les prend dans les tiens
t'as aucune en particulier je n'en ai
jamais pris je ne m'en suis pas plus mal
portée à chaque fois j'en prenais puis
je les tenais plus donc
cette année j'ai fait choc pour prendre
bon défaitiste ou réaliste en tout cas
comme cet homme de nombreux français moi
y compris ont du mal à tenir leurs
bonnes résolutions alors ça sert à rien
mais pourquoi prendre des bonnes
résolutions justement je me suis posé la
même question et j'ai eu ma réponse dans
les archives grâce à ce psychologue en
et bien résolution où il y a
solution et rés c'est à dire retrouver
des solutions
c'est aussi très proche de révolution
c'est refaire un tour sur soi même cette
époque de noël et du nouvel an est
toujours une époque de mort et
renaissance
de il s'est passé quelque chose dans
cette année que je quitte et j'ai envie
qu'il se passe quelque chose dans
l'année qui vient
voilà et bien dans l'année qui vient je
vous souhaite à tous de très bonnes
choses voilà et on en reparlera la
dernière semaine de décembre pour moi
oui gazier vous avez tenu vos bonnes
raisons
[Rires]
[Musique]
on peut débattre de tout sauf des
chiffres il ya des chiffres qui pique
plus qu'une aiguille tous vaccinés tous
protégés alors ses phrases ne sont pas
de moins ce sont quelques-uns des
slogans assénés par les autorités
sanitaires pour vous inciter à vous
faire vacciner contre le coc u19 une
campagne menée à grand renfort de
médiatisation et visiblement cela
fonctionne regardez il ya un an quand le
vaccin est arrivé en france et bien
seulement 40 % des français se disaient
prêts à se faire vacciner contre le coc
vide aujourd'hui plus de 78% de la
population a reçu au moins une dose
bonjour damien mascret alors vous et les
journalistes médecins les
téléspectateurs de france télévisions
vous connaissent bien est ce que toutes
ces campagnes de communication ces pubs
à la télé à la radio pour se faire
vacciner ont joué un rôle alors elle
joue un rôle c'est incontestable
maintenant quel rôle joue-t-elle ça
c'est plus discutable parce que on
s'aperçoit que certaines ont été parfois
contre-productive comme quand on vous
dit vous êtes vacciné vous enlevez vos
masques pour aller voir papy mamie puis
quelques mois plus tard on vous dira
mettez le masque pour aller voir papy
mamie donc on voit que c'est très
difficile de faire une communication de
crise parce que les infos vont vite les
connaissances change rapidement or la
communication reste dans les esprits
alors c'est pas la première campagne de
vaccination lancée en france un camille
en france le père pasteur plusieurs
stratégies ont été déployés par le passé
pour promouvoir les vaccins absolument
et la première stratégie c'était celle
de la contrainte la vaccination
obligatoire c'est ce qui est appliquer
dans le pays dès le début de la
vaccination avec le vaccin contre la
variole en 1902 contre la diphtérie en
38 le tétanos en 40 dans les archives en
1945 à la sortie de la guerre ce qu'on
peut voir et entendre à la télévision
c'est un peu la voix du gouvernement
certains diront la propagande et
naturellement on y montre l'intérêt d'y
avoir une nation en bonne santé et vous
allez l'entendre dans le commentaire du
journaliste dans les images utilisées
tout va dans le sens du contrôle par
l'état de la santé des français
c'est une ambition d'être un peuple 1.5
et le malheur en affaiblissant la santé
a multiplié la contagion le nombre des
beats perruque a doublé depuis 41 chez
les nouveau-nés la mortalité est passée
de 63 à 75 % toutes les maladies sont en
progression dans les vignes pour
aujourd'hui arrêter la contagion cerner
le mal il va devoir procéder à une vaste
révision de la santé française organisé
un contrôle médical de tous les français
comme à montreuil tous les habitants ont
été conviés à se faire examiner il
s'agit de savoir si nous préférons les
jardins aussi nickel
on l'a entendu dans les archives savoir
si l'on préfère les cimetières jardins
au cimetière à cette époque l'état prend
en charge la santé des français est ce
que c'est à ce moment là qu'on prend en
compte finalement un peu la santé
publique mais alors on commence à
prendre en compte la santé publique et
c'est vrai qu'il faut se remettre dans
le contexte de l'époque on a quand même
plus de trois mille décès par an de la
diphtérie aujourd'hui personne ne meurt
de la diphtérie ça nous paraît
inconcevable mais à l'époque il ya
vraiment une question de 1 peut-être pas
le cimetière mais en tout cas il ya
vraiment un risque majeur et c'est vrai
aussi que l'état a une vocation cette
fois ci on est en plein en pleine
éclosion au des vaccins a une vocation à
protéger sa population donc mêlés - mais
les moyens alors ont contraint les
français à se faire vacciner
on filme même les vaccinations ça me
rappelle quelque chose oui oui mais oui
on n'a pas attendu le coup vite pour ça
en 1957 vaccination massive
médiatisation massive on est dans un
petit village savoyard abel entre 500
habitants auront à peu près et une
caméra donc filmé les débuts de la
vaccination contre la poliomyélite
le journaliste évoque même les honneur
d'abord reçu la première vaccination
c'est la petite commune sauvegarde de
belles entre qui a eu les honneurs de la
première vaccination massive tous les
enfants et les jeunes gens soit presque
la moitié de la population du village
ont reçu une dose de vaccin mis au point
par l'institut pasteur de la réprobation
caractérisée à la différence la plus
évidente toute une gamme de pignons a
été commise est ce que c'est
mais finalement c'est la meilleure des
publicités pour une vaccination un
enfant comme ça qui ne dit rien alors
c'est la meilleure des publicités pour
ceux qui croient à la vaccination
n'oublions pas que dès cette époque on a
déjà des mouvements anti vaccins qui ne
croient pas et qu'ils voient ça comme
une abomination justement de mettre en
images les enfants qui sont en train de
se faire vacciner d'ailleurs la contre
offensive ne va pas tarder puisque on va
voir des documents des prospectus des
tracts on voit des enfants parfois
défiguré soi-disant justement par une
infection consécutive à une vaccination
il avance et la contre offensive alors
autre vaccin qui va être accompagnée
d'une grande campagne de communication
camille sée le vaccin contre la
tuberculose en dea en 1950 exactement
c'est un vaccin qui est plus connu sous
le nom du vaccin bcg mise au point donc
par l'institut pasteur alors regardez on
est en 1959 dans une salle de classe et
il ya une sorte d'éducation sanitaire
qui est donné aux élèves au tableau on
peut lire la tuberculose le dépistage
les symptômes bref c'est un peu un spot
publicitaire à l'ancienne et puis en
1962 on faisait des campagnes de pub
déjà et qui ressemblait un petit peu à
de la prévention routière
nul aujourd'hui ne songe à prendre la
route sans assurance le fait il qu'on ne
manquerait pas chemin faisant de le lui
rappeler
pensez aussi en vous engageant sur les
routes de la vie que le bcg est à sa
manière une assurance sur la vie lieu
une assurance de vie c'est ce que la
nouvelle campagne contre la tuberculose
encore vous rappelez damien mascret est
ce que le vaccin est un produit comme un
autre et ce qu'on peut vendre le vaccin
comme on vend une assurance alors bon
c'est certainement pas un produit comme
un autre c'est même pas un médicament
comme un autre puisque vous savez qu'on
peut faire de la publicité pour certains
vaccins alors que la publicité pour les
médicaments de prescription sont
interdites par exemple donc on voit bien
qu'il ya une particularité et puis
surtout il ya une particularité c'est
qu'on la donne des personnes qui sont en
bonne santé et donner un traitement à
quelqu'un qui en bonne santé ça paraît
un petit peu contre intuitif ce qui
explique d'ailleurs là aussi que les
mouvements anti wagon se nourrir d'un
naturalisme qui est laisser faire la
nature vous faites n'importe quoi en
injectant un microbe c'est le terrain
qui compte etc on va changer de périodes
de faire un bond dans les années 70
camille avec avec une nouvelle stratégie
mais oui nouvelle stratégie puisque les
vaccins ne sont plus obligatoires mais
simplement recommandés et ça change tout
puisque les pouvoirs publics vont
maintenant devoir redoubler d'efforts
pour donner envie aux français de se
faire vacciner
des spots tv des brochures on entend
aussi à la radio des spots pour inciter
donc les français qui est un petit peu
comme aujourd'hui comme aujourd'hui
exactement parce qu'il faut convaincre
et non contraindre les français c'est
donc une politique d'incitation cette
fois en
1990 contre la rougeole les oreillons et
la rubéole une campagne de publicité est
lancé et une sorte clairement de pub
pour des couches culottes et diffusé à
la télévision et attention avec un
petite musique qui rentre rapidement
dans la tête
[Musique]
il faut
pas bien c'est faux
bush alors ayant rubéole pas
d'hésitation vaccination damien mascret
ce que ce genre de communication
finalement on ne risque pas d'avoir
l'effet inverse que certains se disent
on en fait vraiment trop pour nous
inciter à la vaccination c'est louche
ben c'est un peu louche je fais ça
s'explique parce qu'à l'époque on a un
petit peu passés d'une vaccination qui
était faite par l'état finalement
d'ailleurs la production était souvent
nationale à une production qui est
devenu très industrielle ce sont les
grands groupes d'ailleurs qui se sont
regroupés entre les années 70 et 90 qui
se regroupent qui sont plus puissants et
qui utilise les méthodes qu'elles sont
toujours utilisés c'est à dire la
publicité alors le risque est bien
encore une fois c'est de nourrir ce
sentiment de business autour de la santé
de business des vaccins et donc on voit
bien que les mouvement antivaccin
s'alimenter là aussi de cette puissance
finalement commerciale qui est un petit
peu suspect puis vous en parliez à
l'instant l'état va devoir faire face à
la montée des anti vaccins oui alors ils
ont toujours existé mais on en parle
essentiellement à partir des années 90
au moment du vaccin contre l'hépatite b
un vaccin qui a été mise en cause un
temps qui favorisait pour certains des
scléroses en plaques un vaccin qui
d'ailleurs lui aussi a eu un joli spot
publicitaire regarder ça ça les fatigue
n'est pas question de prendre de risques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour éviter cette grave maladie il y à
une protection le vaccin
l'hépatite b se faire vacciner c'est
l'éviter
voilà donc se faire vacciner n'est pas
une pub pour les vélos non c'est pas une
pub pour les vélos c'est bien pour le
vaccin se faire vacciner c'est l'éviter
dit slogan mais pour les antilles vague
c'est surtout le vaccin qu'on veut
éviter et donc dans les années 80 90 on
les entend écouter l'un des membres de
la ligue pour les libertés des
vaccinations et les vaccinations sont
devenus une véritable religion d'état
jusqu'à maintenant les gens sont
conditionnés dans le système vaccinale
parce qu'il manque d'informations la
formation des accidents ne s'écrit pas
où il ya beaucoup plus d'accidents que
des lacs cepgl prétend il dit manquaient
d'information est ce qu a pris une part
de vérité là-dedans peut-être que l'état
fait trop de publicité et pas assez
d'information il complètement envoie
toujours le côté négatif de lentillac
cynisme mais en réalité il ya un côté
positif c'est justement que ça a poussé
à avoir des législations parfois
d'ailleurs à la suite d'événements
dramatiques alors des législation plus
stricte sur le contrôle par exemple de
la qualité des produits des législations
parfois aussi que obtenu compte beaucoup
plus de finalement de l'individu au sens
de pas d'expérimentations pas de
vaccination de masse avant d'avoir pris
des précautions finalement tout s'est
construit un petit peu de concert avec
les opposants et les pros et on a trouvé
une sorte d'équilibré aujourd'hui on a
une production qui est très sûr de la
vaccination face à cette défiance aller
les politiques vont devoir rassurer
quand la publicité ne suffit pas et
certains vont même donné de leur
personne oui exactement nathanel on s'en
souvient tous je crois en 2009 avec le
vaccin contre la grippe a la campagne de
vaccination a muté en campagne de
communication politique vous le voyez
devant les caméras roselyne bachelot la
ministre de la santé de l'époque se fait
donc piqué d'autres élus comme eric
ciotti christian etr estrosi ont fait
tomber leur chemise mais ça ne suffira
pas on connaît le flop de ce vaccin on a
vu ces scènes également contre le covin
est ce que les politiques doivent
médiatiser leur vaccination c'est
toujours compliqué effectivement parce
que s'ils le font effectivement on dit
que il ya une sorte de mise en scène on
a même vu sur les réseaux parfois l'idée
que ça n'avait pas été vraiment injecté
on voit bien la façon dont la fermière
tient à la seringue ou l'infirmier donc
on voit bien que quel que soit le
message qui est diffusée de toute façon
ceux qui croient continueront de se dire
tout c'est rassurant et ceux qui ont des
doutes continuerons à dire ça après tout
c'est une mise en scène les politiques
sont pas les seuls d'ailleurs
s'appliquer eh bien non si on revient un
vaccin un petit peu plus traditionnel je
dirais saisonniers celui contre la
grippe et bien des personnalités des
stars du petit écran font la promotion
de ce vaccin comme en 2015 aujourd'hui
pas de champions et pas de question mais
une affirmation la grippe est une
maladie dangereuse ça va bien oui les
enfants mes jeunes comme moi mais
certains d'entre vous ne se méfie pas de
lag et pourtant si le moyen le plus
efficace de vous protéger et vous vous
êtes vacciné
quel est l'effet espéré d'agneau mascré
de demander à des personnalités comme ça
d'appeler les bouchons à la sphère
d'invités est également une centaine
d'enfants leurs émissions tout à fait
c'est vrai que deux des gens c'est vrai
qu'on dit toujours que le médecin et
dans le médicament par exemple mais de
toute façon appartement quelqu'un
recommande quelque chose évidemment
qu'on a tendance à associer le produit
comme diraient les experts du marketing
est la personne qu'il défend et bah
quand on prend des personnes
sympathiques en qui on a confiance et
qui nous disent que c'est bien
évidemment qu'on a tendance à se poser
moins de questions sur la qualité du
produit alors pour le coc vite beaucoup
de personnalités ont également
médiatisé alors leur injection un line
renaud ou encore kylie ann m bape est
sûre sur twitter qui a posté en mai
dernier cette photo de lui au moment de
sa vaccination quel regard vous portez
dr masqué sur cette médiatisation plutôt
inédite des vaccins mais je pense que
c'est un nouvel outil que de toute façon
les stars 2 qu'on a vu deux devaient
adopter parce que c'est aussi un outil
qui est largement utilisé par les
mouvements anti vaccins donc il est
question d'être présent sur le terrain
des deux côtés ina on a les deux camps à
la fois qu'ils sont eux qui vont
s'opposer donc il faut être présent sur
le terrain mais ce qui est assez
étonnant aussi avec ce vaccin est
peut-être inédit c'est que des français
lambda aussi médiatise leur propre
vaccination on a tous sur nos réseaux
sociaux des amis de la famille qui
postent son bras au moment de la
troisième injection qui postent son pass
vaccinale c'est assez étonnant aussi que
ça ait touché les français cette
médiatisation oui alors c'est vrai qu'il
ya une pression quand même sociale très
forte sur la vaccination est d'ailleurs
il ya une pression
r sur ceux qui ne sont pas vaccinés là
aussi qui n'est peut-être pas très
légitime parce qu'on sait bien qu'ils
ont en partie pour certains étaient
manipulés d'autres des conditions certes
et donc il faut bien prendre conscience
finalement que cette pression fait qu'à
un moment il faut s'en libérer ou en
tout cas la montre est c'est à dire que
j'ai une telle pression à faire vacciner
que je montre que je suis vacciné à
l'inversé une telle pression ne pas me
faire vacciner que je refuse et je me
mets dans des actions où on voit que je
ne veux pas je ne veux pas du vaccin
donc finalement se mettre en scène c'est
devenu un petit peu la clé de notre
époque et les réseaux sociaux le
permettent et surtout on sait maintenant
qu'on peut être recruté reliques et
c'est donc finalement ça amplifie ce
mouvement avec ce risque tout de même
inquiets que finalement les deux camps
peuvent paraître équilibré alors qu'on
sait très bien que les gens qui font
bien dans leur coin ne vont pas aller se
médiatiser donc les militants prennent
un petit peu le terrain là aussi
dernière est ce que le changement du
pass sanitaires on passe vaccinale
finalement une obligation de se faire
vacciner qui ne dit pas son nom c'est
pas un constat d'échec pour pour la
politique la médiatisation des campagnes
alors complètement on voit bien que le
gouvernement à chaque fois essayer de
gagner un petit peu de terrain sur
justement les réticents les hésitants
sans penser à l'est d'ailleurs jusqu'aux
antilles vagues ce radicaux mais à
chaque fois finalement il a fallu
trouver des subterfuges augmenter un
petit peu la pression en espérant gagner
un petit peu l'étape ultime serait tout
de même de passer finalement à
l'obligation vaccinale mais sans aucun
contrôle ce qui serait une façon de dire
nous on vous a dit que c'était bien et
qu'il fallait le faire maintenant vous
prenez vos responsabilités on ne
contrôle même plus merci mille fois
damien mascret pour toutes ces
explications on vous retrouve sur les
antennes de france télévisions c'est
quasiment tous les jours allez vous dire
malheureusement en ce moment et merci à
vous camille pour cet intéressant
travail historique sur la vaccination on
se quitte avec notre traditionnel et
pitt c'est mireille mathieu qui nous
souhaiter une bonne année à sa manière
en 1973
prenant
non je la vois tes yeux
n'a rien on est bien
tous les deux
mais
c'est le bo
m
[Musique]
au coin
la bonne année voilà la bonne année
j'adore mathieu la bonne année à vous
plein de bonheur encore une fois en 2022
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
sur le canal 27 et toute la semaine bien
sûr sur les réseaux sociaux que ce soit
ceux de l'ina ou ceux de france info
émission préparée avec les
documentalistes et mini galtier claire
brûlé merci à elle et merci à vous
d'être là toutes les semaines à nous
regarder